[MUSIC PLAYING]
FENG LU: Hi.
Good morning, everyone.
Welcome to the Pandora
and Composer session.
It's not a music session, sadly.
But you will probably learn
how Composer helps Pandora
to manage their music data.
So I'm Feng.
I'm a software engineer
at Google Cloud.
Also joining me today are
Daniel from Pandora and Wilson
too from Google
Cloud Composer team.
So we'll start the
talk by giving folks
an overview of what
is Cloud Composer?
What kind of problem
we're trying to solve,
and what are some of the
features in Cloud Composer?
And then we'll follow
it by Daniel onstage
talking about Pandora's
experience of migrating
their workflow extrusion
to Google Cloud.
And we'll wrap up
the talk by some
of the newer and
latest features that
were just recently released.
So we live in an
increasingly complex world.
In the context of
data analytics,
this means your data probably
live in many different places.
And every once in
a while, there'll
be a new data processing
framework that get announced.
And maybe once you're done
with your data processing,
there might be different places
you need to upload your data
processing results.
You eventually realize
that it's very unlikely
that you can finish all
your data processing needs
in a single system.
It's very common that you
have to stage data processing
jobs in different systems
together, and essentially put
them in a form of a workflow.
And once you have a workflow,
then ultimately comes
the need of, you want to be
able to schedule that workflow.
You want to monitor
that workflow.
Really, think about a way to
help you to reduce complexity,
it's through automation.
And here, it's really
important that you
have a tool that could
offload and manage
all this complexity of
scheduling and monitoring
workflows on your behalf.
With that purpose
in mind, we designed
and developed Composer.
It's built on top of the popular
open source Apache Airflow.
And then helps you to
create workflows at ease,
making it powerful for you
to manage your workflows.
So exactly how
does Code Composer
helps you to reduce
your workflow management
complexities and help you
to improve your workflow
development?
We focus on a few areas.
I mean, namely the first
one is really about,
we want to make sure Composer
being in the orchestration
choice when it comes to GCP.
So what that means
is, we want to make
sure that from
Cloud Composer, you
could orchestrate and
manage pretty much all
your GCP related workloads.
[INAUDIBLE] jobs data
flow, data proc jobs.
Second thing, as I
mentioned earlier,
we realized that it needed that.
You know, today
your data is likely
going to live in different
places, on prem and on cloud.
So we designed Composer on
day one with that requirement
that whatever
orchestration solution
we're going to introduce,
that needs to work well
in a hybrid cloud environment.
Also, be able to come up
with high abstractions,
and also make it really easy
for you to write your workflow.
Especially now think
about if your workflow
has tens or hundreds
or thousands of tasks.
Again, we want to make
it really easy for you
to be able to act surprised.
Workflows consist of
that many of task.
Finally, to increase
reusability.
Because you have done all
your development on prem,
we don't want it to
be the case that when
you move to Google Cloud,
you realize, oh, now I need
to redevelop all my workflows.
So we really put open source
in the core of Cloud Composer.
And we make sure that
whatever workflows you write
or you develop,
those can run in GCP.
And then likewise, when you move
certain workflows to on prem,
you find out you don't
have to modify anything.
Things should just
work out of the box.
So with those
requirements in mind,
and then we added
a lot of more--
we started design and
development of Cloud Composer.
And then one of the
questions we often
got was, how does Cloud
Composer differentiate
with self-managed
Apache Airflow?
I mean, I understand
probably many of you
have on prem
Airflow deployments.
And you're wondering, what are
some of the value added pieces
if I move to Cloud Composer?
There are quite some of those.
I'm going to probably
highlight a few important ones.
The first one is really
about-- a lot of those
are really sort of
center around simplicity,
and also trying to
help you to minimize
your operational complexities.
So we have really
convenient tooling.
Cloud Console, and
G Cloud for you
to manage your Cloud
Composer environment,
and make it easy for you
to upload your workflow
and inspect workflow status.
Second thing, probably
70% to 80% of people
rely on the Airflow web UI.
And also, frankly
speaking, that's
also one of the
distinct factors that
draw people to Apache Airflow.
So we understand the need.
That's why we put
a lot of thoughts
to make things easier for you
to host your Apache Airflow web
server, and also make
it extremely secure
through our cloud
Identity-Aware proxy.
And then when it comes to--
Airflow has different versions.
Some people choose
to-- there's always
different [INAUDIBLE]
versions, since Airflow
is developing Python.
So again, in Cloud
Composer, we're
really happy to
streamline and simplify
the management of Python
and Airflow versions.
So that in Composer,
you can specify,
and then which
Python and Airflow
version you want to use, and
then also open a path for you
to sort of upgrade
from one Airflow
to a different Airflow version.
Given that it is often
the case that when
you write your
workflow, you realize
that you may have external
library dependencies,
you may have
customized operators.
So that's why we also
make it extremely simple
for you to install and manage
additional PyPi dependencies.
Debugging and monitoring
are common needs these days.
[INAUDIBLE] workflow failures.
So Composer comes out of
box with Stackdriver logging
and the monitoring integration.
So whenever you have issues
regarding to a particular task,
you would be able to find
all the logs in Stackdriver.
And finally, there
are IMs for you
to sort of streamline
your composing environment
management, and
manage permissions
who has access to what.
We launched Cloud Composer
last year during Google Next.
It has probably been
about nine months.
And since then, we added
a lot more GCP operators.
That's really why I
want to highlight here.
As you can see from
the slide, pretty much
we support all debug
of GCP operators.
You know, you have Machine Cloud
AI, Translate, Cloud Vision,
Kubernetes.
On the data side, you have Cloud
SQL, BigTable, [INAUDIBLE],,
and Spanner.
So those are all really
trying to make it easier
for you to write workflows.
So you don't really
have to worry about,
how should I interact
with these new systems?
I also want to, as I mention
that writing workflows are
easy, and Airflow has a very
expressive mechanism for you
to express your workflow.
So in the next couple
of slides, I just
want to show you
a quick overview
of how a DAG or a
workflow is developed
in Composer or Airflow.
So a little bit context, a
history of Apache Airflow.
It's a project that was
originally developed by Airbnb
and subsequently got donated
to Apache Software Foundation.
And since then, it has
gained a lot of popularity
in the community.
It's a very, very
active community.
It has a few hundred
contributors.
Workflows are essentially
expressed as Directed Acyclic
Graph.
That's why you probably have--
for people coming from
the Airflow community,
you probably have heard them
talking a lot about DAGs.
DAGs really essentially
[INAUDIBLE] workflows.
This is an example DAG of how
the Hello world-ish workflow.
It has about a three
task, and then you
run different commands.
And then you have ways
to specify the dependency
among your task.
At the beginning, you
do your standard part,
like standard Python imports.
Those really just
tell Airflow, hey, I
want to [INAUDIBLE]
the D-A-G and the DAG
is the workflow, top
level workflow construct.
And after that, it's just import
whatever operators you think
are useful.
In this case, we
use a bash operator,
but there are a Python
operator, and then
there's a lot of GCP
operators, such as say
run big query, query operator.
So many different
operators are there.
Once you're done
with the import,
then you put all
your orchestration
or scheduling arguments
there, like things
like who are the owner
of this workflow,
how often do you
want to run, when
do you want to start
a workflow, when
do you want to end the
workflow, so on and so forth.
Once you have the arguments set
up, then writing the workflow
itself is actually
really straightforward.
With the top line
DAG definition,
then you can specify your
task, any task that you plan
to contain in that workflow.
So as I mentioned in this
example, we use bash operator.
But you can, in fact,
use any operator.
The nice thing
really about Airflow
is, it has the
flexibility for you
to introduce your own operator.
This is really tying
back to my early point
about it managing complexity.
Be able to come out with
higher level abstractions,
and be able to hide
that complexity
from your internal users
is really one way for us
to navigate this complex
sort of workspace.
Once you put
everything together,
you submit it to Cloud Composer.
From that point
onwards, Composer
will take care of
scheduling, running,
and monitoring your workflows.
This is sort of like a
typical bash web UI for you
to access your workflow.
From there, you would be able
to inspect the graphic structure
of your workflow,
and also you would
be able to inspect
different logs when
it comes to individual task.
They also have a rich
set of dashboarding
for you to inspect, if you
put all your task runs,
workflow runs together, how does
the processing time fluctuates
across different time runs?
Sometimes that helps
you to detect anomaly
in your workflow.
Behind the scene,
this is what happens.
Cloud Composer creates a
collection of GCP resources.
And then leveraging those
resources [INAUDIBLE]
those resources are
collectively known
as cloud composing environment.
And then within
that environment, we
host Airflow
scheduler worker web
server the database, and
then the workflow storage.
The same workflow storage
is also used for you
to store workflow artifacts.
And then once you have
your DAGs there, then
you will be able to
orchestrate and connect
to a host set of
external systems.
Earlier I showed you
really a simple example,
but then really that can
be as complicated as this.
Although the graph
itself looks complicated,
but actually the code behind
the graph isn't that hard.
So this is--
I just want to say that
this is a real DAG we
use within the Cloud Composer
team to sort of dynamically
generate Airflow docker images.
That's so far about
a quick overview
of Composer and Airflow.
Next I'll hand over to Daniel
to talk about Pandora's move
to Cloud Composer.
DANIEL BARRETT: Good morning.
My name is Daniel Barrett.
I'm a staff engineer at Pandora.
I'm here to talk today about our
move to GCP with Cloud Composer
from on prem Airflow.
Just to give a little history
on the scheduling at Pandora.
Originally when I
started, we had a system
of legacy Java schedulers.
And they were based in Java.
They used the Quartz framework
as the actual scheduler.
They were completely
developed in house.
So because they were
developed in house,
it was very hard for engineers,
analysts outside of analytics,
to create jobs in the framework.
There wasn't a whole lot
of online support either.
It was all based off of whatever
we documented internally.
It had a limited UI that
we developed ourselves.
If we wanted to
add new features,
we had to go out and
develop them ourselves.
That also took place
when you're doing
other work and other tasks.
So a lot of times it was very
slow to be developed in the UI.
About two years ago, we started
our migration to Airflow.
The Airflow UI is full of
features and incredibly easy
to use.
It has support, as Feng showed
you, for various technologies
within Google Cloud.
And then also
regular technologies
that allow you to integrate
with Hive and Hadoop and things
like that we use to do
our analytics processing.
It has a very large
online support community.
If you run into
any problems, it's
very easy to be able to
Google it and look it up,
and somebody else has probably
run into that same problem,
and will allow you to
be able to figure out
a solution to your problem.
It is all written in
Python and is incredibly
easy to develop new
operators and sensors that
will do custom tasks for you.
Things that you do over and
over and over again, you
can put those into operators and
allow other developers to use
them much more
simply and not have
to reinvent the
wheel every time.
Because it was open
source and there
was a large community
behind it, it
was very easy to onboard
new engineers that
had experience using Airflow.
It was not a lot
of ramp up time.
In our previous one, there was
quite a bit of ramp up time,
and a period where people were
getting used to the legacy Java
scheduler.
That didn't have to
happen in Airflow.
There was another issue
that we came across,
and a lot of our
analysts at Pandora
would use Cron to be able
to schedule their Hive
scripts in the past.
This obviously is
not a great solution.
And it was very
easy for us to be
able to integrate the analysts
to create Airflow tasks
and jobs that could
depend on other jobs
and things of that nature.
That made it much more
simpler and robust than just
running a Cron
script using Hive.
We were also able
to use a sensor
to depend on other
analytics jobs
completion outside of
your actual Airflow
instance on prem.
After those two
years, now we have
approximately about 90
instances between development
and production in Pandora.
Airflow has been adopted
very widely and very quickly.
So there are five
problems that we looked at
that we had to solve when we
moved from Airflow to Composer.
One of them was
during the migration,
Composer and Airflow
were both running
in cloud and on prem, and the
issues between running them
in two locations.
There was also the
question of, how
do we depend on a job
finishing in either location?
And then Composer is a true
distributive framework.
On prem, we made the decision to
deploy Composer to a single VM,
so that it was a lot
simpler for the deployment,
so that we did not have
to manage a distributed
deployment of Airflow on prem.
And then how do we
support analysts
in creating jobs
that run on dataproc?
Back on prem, they were used
to having a Hadoop cluster that
was always on that they
could submit jobs to anytime.
Now they had to figure
out how to actually
run stuff on dataproc itself.
And then finally,
how do we deploy
code to Composer from an on prem
Bitbucket or a repository on
prem?
So the first one that we
solved was the job dependency
solution.
So for that, we have a
Postgres database on prem.
Eventually we'll move
that to the cloud.
And there is a meta service
REST API container that
sits in front of that
Postgres database
that handles requests for jobs
or tables that are finished
or code that is asking, is
something finished for the day.
So that allows jobs or
tables to be set as complete
for a specific day parameter.
It would also allow you to get
the status of a job or table
for a very specific day.
And so around that, we
created an Airflow sensor
that would ask the meta service
if a dependency is fulfilled.
If you are depending
on job x, you
would create that
sensor in your workflow.
And it would say, is job x
done for April 1 of 2019.
And then on the
flip side, we also
created an operator that at the
end of the Airflow workflow,
you could set your
dependency as complete--
your table, your job, whatever
it is that you were running.
So this is what that looks
like from the architecture.
In here we have two
Composer instances
that are running in GCP
and two Airflow on prem.
There is the meta service
with the Postgres service,
Postgres database backing it.
So for this instance,
we would have
a job populating a table running
on Composer instance number
one.
That job, the several jobs
that are waiting on that table
to be done on Composer instance
number two and on prem three
and four.
After the table is
populated in Composer one,
it would send a status
done to that meta service
in that Postgres database.
And then the meta
service would then
tell two, three, and four
that that job is now complete.
And then their workflows would
be able to move on from there.
There are a couple of approach
drawbacks to this in GCP.
One is that, because we are
Postgres instances on prem,
and because we have
on prem instances,
it is required that we need a
VPC network for our Composer
instances in GCP.
So currently, due to
our networking model
that we decided in GCP,
we use shared VPCs.
And currently you can
only have one shared VPC
network per Composer instance.
So in a specific
project, that means
that we can only have one
Composer instance that uses
that job dependency framework.
And also, if you have a
table that needs historical,
and for some reason it
happened before we set up
this framework, and those
tables or those jobs
are not done in that
framework, then we
need some kind of
dependency override
to be able to process history
where the dependencies are not
set in the past.
So the next problem we do
is dealing with Celery.
So Celery is the asynchronous
task queue job scheduler used
as the workers in Composer.
And it has some drawbacks.
So specifically,
I had a job that
was a scientist job that
had three pipelines that
were highly parallelized
that we were
going to move to GCP last year.
So I took these pipelines,
and I knew that it
had three distinct parts.
And I ran them manually
on specific machines
to determine what
type of machine
could handle each
individual task.
From that, I determined
the actual machine time
that I was going to use
to handle these pipelines.
So originally what
I did is I set up
Composer with three worker nodes
with the very specific machine
type that I knew I wanted to
be able to handle this task.
It was an
n1-standard-16, 16 cores.
When it came to actually
scheduling those tasks,
the Celery scheduler calls
those nodes to be overwhelmed.
Because what it would
do is it would actually
schedule two tasks on
one node and one task
on another node and then
nothing on the third node.
It was not an even
scheduling of tasks itself.
And because my node type
couldn't handle more than one
of the pipelines, it
would cause it to freeze.
So this is what it looked like
when it would actually execute.
You would have the scheduler.
It would execute one of them
on worker one, two of them
on worker two, and nothing
running on worker three.
So the solution that I'd
used to get around this
is I created three VM instances
of the type of machine
that I wanted to.
And I named them processor
one, two, and three.
And then I shut those
machine instances down.
I then set up Composer
with three normal nodes,
n1-standard-4.
And then I set up
the Composer DAG
to use those processor machines.
And what I would do
is, my task would
FCP fresh code from Composer
over to the processor
machines themselves.
And then it would use an SSH
command to run the pipeline
on each individual instance.
So this enabled the
actual processing
to happen on the
processing machines
and not on the
Composer nodes itself.
So what would happen
there is my scheduler
would schedule on worker
one and two on worker two,
but then those
workers would actually
execute the code on the actual
processor machines themselves.
So I ended up with one
task running on one,
one task running on two, and
one task running on three.
This enabled the process to
happen the way that I actually
wanted it to happen.
At the end of the processing,
when everything was done,
I would then shut down
processor one, two,
and three so we were
no longer getting
charged to use those nodes.
This is what the
resulting DAG looked like.
If you look at the
very beginning,
you'll see a start
VM instances task.
This is where I would start up
processor one, two, and three.
And then I would wait for those
instances to fully start up.
I then had tasks to
FCP the code over
to each one of
those VM instances.
And then I would
run the scripts.
And then it would have a
couple of different tasks
that would do some other
processing and some local data
cleanup on each one
of those VM instances.
And then at the very end,
you see at the very last one,
I would stop all three
of those VM instances
because we don't need
them running until they're
ready to go the next day.
So the next problem
we had to look at was,
how do we make Dataproc
easier for analysts to use?
Analysts, like I
said before, they're
used to having a Hadoop
cluster that is always on
and accepts their
jobs at any time.
They may have to
wait for resources,
but they could just
fire off queries
and fire off tasks and send
them to this Hadoop cluster.
Dataproc is a little
bit different than that.
Dataproc you have
to know a little bit
to be able to create
a Dataproc instance.
You have to understand it
a little bit more-- what
are worker nodes,
some of the properties
that are needed to start
up a Dataproc instance.
So like I said, it
was a bar to entry
for analysts to use the Dataproc
to run their schedule queries.
So what we ended up developing
was a batch job framework.
And this was developed with
a Google contractor called
Neudesic.
This was a batch
job framework that
requires minimal coding
and really hardly
any Dataproc
knowledge whatsoever.
It would require them
to create config files
that just defined their SQL,
the SQL tasks that they had,
and the variables
that were going
to be put into those SQL tasks.
And then the DAG was dynamically
configured from those config
files themselves.
The config files would define
external and intertagged
dependencies, sensors based
off of other jobs that
were running on other
Airflow instances on prem,
the piece that I
showed you earlier.
You would define those in the
config files for your SQL.
And you would also
define inside of the DAG
what SQL files
depended on other ones
so that they could then be
set up correctly in a DAG.
It would also provide a way to
instantiate a Dataproc cluster
for each SQL statement run
using only the number of workers
needed.
And to do this,
there was a heavy use
of Dataproc workflow templates.
The Dataproc workflow
templates would start up
a cluster for the batch job.
They would run the SQL
file on that cluster.
And then they would delete
that cluster afterwards.
And we found that this was
the best way to use Dataproc.
It was repeatable and
was less prone to error
than some of the
other ways that we
looked at running Dataproc and
running SQL files on Dataproc.
This was all the code
that was required
to be able to create
this dynamic DAG.
So this create
batch DAG operator
was what actually went through
all of the config files
and constructed the DAG itself.
This code can be copied from
one project to the next one.
So the analysts
would not really need
to know any Python whatsoever in
order to run their batch jobs.
This could be high.
This could be Spark.
And several of the different
ways of running stuff.
From that code came
this DAG right here.
So this DAG was created
using that code,
using config files that
were set up for it.
Like I said, it was a
minimal amount of code
to be able to create
something as complex as this.
This is one of our largest
jobs, called our nightly job.
And it's a great name.
But there is a lot of--
you'll see on the
left, there are
all of our external
sensors, that
were other jobs on other Airflow
or imports or things like that,
that we were waiting on
to be complete in order
for our process to start.
Each one of those
pieces would have--
there would be data
quality checks involved
in that, where after the
table was completely loaded,
it would do duplicate checks
or threshold checks or things
of that nature.
So that you would ensure
that your data was
up to your standards at
the end of the process.
And then at the
very end, it would
set its status as complete
for each individual table
back in our analytics
Postgres database
and allow other jobs to
be kicked off from that.
So one of the
other ones was, how
do we deploy code from on
prem Pandora to Composer
in the cloud?
So the ways that we came up
with to deploy, one of them
would be an on
prem Jenkins build
that uses a plug-in
that Google has
for Jenkins to be able to push
code to a Composer DAG bucket.
All of your code in Composer
is synced to a bucket.
So whenever you create
a Composer instance,
there is a Composer bucket that
is assigned to that instance.
Inside of there, there is
a DAGs folder, and also
a plugins folder.
These are the two
places that you
need to deploy your code in
order to run them in Composer.
You can also just
drag and drop manually
into the Composer bucket
using Google's console UI.
That is a very simple way,
but it's also a manual way.
So the other one would be
more of an automated build.
The second one would be
more of a manual process.
But something we came
up with at Pandora,
because a lot of our
analysts are not really
used to command
line performance,
and so we came up
with a view that
would allow them to
use a web page to sync
a project from Bitbucket.
This view looks like this.
And this view when
you pulled it up
would go out to our
internal Bitbucket repo.
And will pull all of
the internal Pandora
publicly available
Bitbucket repositories.
You can select which
one you wanted.
You could select the
branch you wanted,
and then individually you
could select the commit
that you wanted.
And then when you
push Submit, it
would sync that code to the
DAGs folder on the server
that it was running
on on Pandora.
So we had to take this
and move it to Composer
to be able to do the
same kind of thing.
So on prem, the view would
build the git command
and then sync directly
to the file system
because it would run the git
command as an external process
in Python.
On Composer, the
web server is not
running on the Kubernetes
Composer cluster.
So the web server doesn't
have access to the file system
where your DAGs are
located or the data
directory that you're allowed
to do work in on Composer
is located.
So we had to think of it a
little bit differently way.
And we had to create a DAG to
take care of any web server
action, and then send the DAG
arguments from the web server
itself.
That is because of this Composer
architecture right here.
You'll see that the workers, the
Redis, the Airflow scheduler,
and the Cloud SQL proxy are
all running on the Kubernetes
Engine.
But the Airflow web server is
running on the tenant project.
So it did not have access to the
file system on the Kubernetes
cluster itself.
The downsides to a DAG sync
are the Composer bucket
is syncing down to the container
file system, but not back up.
So you could not just sync the
code to the actual local file
system where the DAGs are
located because it would
be overwritten the
next time that Google
synced your code from the bucket
down to the file system itself.
Another one is that
Bitbucket projects
must be made public
within the organization
in order to view them
to pull a list of them.
Pulls, because of the network
from on prem to bucket,
are a little slow.
This is to be expected
because you're pulling them
up to Google Composer.
You have to sync the project
code to home Airflow GCS data
before doing an rsync up
to the Composer bucket.
The home Airflow GCS data
was just a temporary location
in order to sync the code there.
So we did not have to overwrite
everything in the bucket
every time that we wanted to
do a pull from the bucket.
And that is it for me.
And I will hand you
over right now, sir.
WILSON LIAN: Hi, everybody.
I'm Wilson Lian.
I'm a software engineer on
the Cloud Composer team.
And today I have the
privilege of telling you
all about some new features
that we've rolled out recently
in Cloud Composer.
So something that we've heard
a lot from our customers is,
how can I monitor
my environments
to make sure that they're
up and running and healthy
and making progress on
DAGs, as well as determine
whether or not I've
provisioned enough resources
for my environment to
make progress-- or sorry,
to handle the workload
that I'm throwing at it?
And so to answer that question,
our Composer data plane
is now exporting metrics
into Stackdriver.
As you see here, we're
exporting information
about the quantity and latency
of both DAG runs and task
instances.
So you can see if
anything has gotten stuck.
We're also exporting information
about the health of the Celery
queue, including the number
of Celery workers that are up
and the length of the queue.
Now let's flip over
to the demo screen,
and I'll show you how you
can use these metrics.
OK, so you can see here, I
built this dashboard earlier.
Basically we're showing
on the left column
the number of DAG runs
and task runs over time.
And on the right column, we
have the latency of DAG runs
and task runs over time.
So if we zoom in
on the one hour,
we can see that we have
four DAG runs per hour
for a single particular DAG.
Called sometimes slow.
And we can see on
the right hand side,
that the latency of
that DAG run varies
over the course of an hour.
In fact, once
every hour it takes
much longer than the other
DAG runs in that hour.
And if we look
down at the task, I
happen to know that
this DAG has two tasks.
One of them is
called consistent1.
It's a bash operator.
And it runs fairly consistently.
And the other one is
called sometimesslow,
and it's a Python operator.
And I cheated for this
demo, and I made it
so that sometimesslow
checks the time,
and once an hour makes
itself one minute slower
than every other
time that it runs.
So this is a bit of
a contrived example,
but you could see how, if you
had some external dependency
that was introducing
latency into your DAG runs,
you would be able to see this
in a Stackdriver monitoring
console.
And additionally,
you could go in
and create an alerting policy.
And let's do that right now.
We'll create an alert so that
whenever that task is slow,
we get an email.
So we'll filter that
by the task name
and say whenever sometimesslow
takes longer than 60 seconds,
for one minute we
will get an email
or some other notification.
This is just standard
Stackdriver monitoring stuff.
And then we can save that.
And likewise, we could
do a similar thing
for the Celery queue.
Normally a Celery queue
length of zero is a good sign.
That means that your
workers are able to keep up
with the offered load.
So we could set up an
alert on the Celery queue.
And whenever it exceeds some
threshold, we can get an alert
and realize that we need
to do some reprovisioning.
So now let's swap back
to the slides, please.
So the next feature that
I'm going to talk about
is one that you can
use to help improve
the security of your Cloud
Composer environments.
So whenever you create a
Cloud Composer environment,
as Dan pointed out, the
Cloud Composer control plane
is going to create a GKE cluster
and Cloud SQL instance for you.
And by default, the VMs for
the GKE cluster and Cloud SQL
instance will have public
IPs, meaning that they
are externally routable.
And you can be reached from
anyone on the internet.
Moreover, the communication
to your Airflow database
in the Cloud SQL instance will
traverse the public internet.
So what this means is,
your traffic potentially
traverses the public internet.
And if you have a
zero day vulnerability
in some daemon running
on your system,
it could be exploited by
someone on the internet.
However, with
private IP clusters,
we only assign internal
non-publicly routable IP
addresses to all of your GKE VMs
and the Cloud SQL instance VM.
Optionally, you can
enable a feature
which will put the Kubernetes
master for your GKE
cluster behind a
private only IP as well.
So let's swap back
to the demo screen,
and I'll show you how
you can create this.
You can do this using the beta
channel of the G Cloud tool.
But you can also do
this in the GCP console
by enabling beta features
up in the top right corner.
Let's just look at what a
private IP cluster looks like.
OK, so I precreated this
private IP cluster earlier.
You can see that a private
environment is set to true,
and I have master external
access set to false.
So the Kubernetes master should
only have an internal IP.
So if we drill down
into the GKE cluster
that's associated
with this, we can
see that the master endpoint
has an IP address, 172.16.0.2,
which is an internal IP address.
And if we look at the
node pool to check out
the GCE VMs that were
allocated for this,
we see that they
have no external IPs.
The last feature that
I like to touch on
is one that we've been
working on for a long time.
And basically, let's say
you're really excited,
when you get out of here, to
go and try out the Stackdriver
monitoring feature or
some of the new features
that you've seen us
announce in recent releases.
In the past, we would have asked
you to create a new environment
and then move all your
DAGs over, and then
move all your Airflow metadata
over to the new environment,
and then take down
the old environment.
Now, with just the
push of a button,
you can upgrade your
environments in place
and preserve the VMs, the
Cloud SQL instance, and all
your Airflow metadata
on the same environment,
while still running the
latest version of Composer
or even an upgraded
version of Airflow.
I can try to demo
this, but we'll
see if we're able to try that.
Let's go back to
the demo screen.
So I have this environment here
that's ready to be upgraded.
I've enabled beta features.
And we can see that it's running
Composer 1.3.0 and Airflow
1.9.0.
So if we just hit the
Upgrade Image Version button,
we can select a
new image version.
1.6.1 is our most
recent version.
And let's upgrade to the
latest version of Airflow.
Submit.
And then the upgrades
is in-flight.
It'll complete in a few minutes.
And then you'll be at
the latest version.
That's all I have.
For more information on
Cloud Composer or Airflow,
you can check out these links.
[MUSIC PLAYING]